what is your opinion on
when you come from a place like Chicago
where
a lot of conflict is rooted from a very
real place
um I feel like the last few years we've
seen
hip-hop beef
people who aren't from the same place
not even anyone specifically exactly but
people who aren't even from the same
state people who do not grow up around
each other have serious beef that is
equal Bloodshed life being lost like to
me it's like a shame when I see that
[ __ ] it's like really and a lot of it is
the internet the IG the Twitter all this
[ __ ] but like you know I just feel like
um uh we got to figure out a way to try
to nip that kind of [ __ ] in the butt
like if someone's from the same place
and they got's cool it's not even cool
I'm not cool understandable but the rap
beef [ __ ] I'm like man especially if
it's from people who come from a place
where they know what beef is it's like
what's the point of like having like a
real beef with another rapper who's not
even from where you're from exactly I
feel like it's unnecessary and and
anyway you know what I'm saying it
that's why I try to like stay in my Lane
because I unders I understand it I get
it I get why people have differences and
they think like oh I just react this way
and maybe sometimes they go straight to
the internet which make it even more
bigger because yeah they not from the
same state that's the only form of
communication at that point so it's like
you making [ __ ] bigger than what it is
instead of just getting on the phone a
lot of [ __ ] avoid getting on the phone
a lot of [ __ ] avoid being accountable
for their actions a lot of [ __ ] scared
to get on that phone and say damn I bet
this is what it is this is the
misunderstanding well maybe we should
link right here and we could settle it
you know a lot of [ __ ] get on that
internet and it's like
and it [ __ ] could be something as simple
as a phone call two [ __ ] getting on
the phone that don't nobody know so easy
nobody nobody even need to know the
nature of the conversation but when you
go on the internet and you saying
something about this [ __ ] you don't
know it's a hundred other [ __ ] that
love him also you know what probably not
even on that but a hundred other [ __ ]
that love him now you can't even do a
show in this city you can't do this you
can't do that and it become real beef
when y'all ain't from the city and it
ain't no blood [ __ ] it become blood [ __ ]
over Pride over some internet and you
know what I think some people are scared
to get on the phone because they're
afraid of this internet [ __ ]
filming it but at the end of the day
it's like if you confident as a man
if you on the phone saying some sucker
[ __ ] then that's your problem that's
your problem yeah if you're on the
internet seeing [ __ ] I'm listening then
you get on the phone and say some sucker
[ __ ] you deserve to get recorded right
right right right but if you're on the
phone being a man and being solid yeah
it ain't even that serious bro I feel
like you did this I did this [ __ ] it
it's cool bro it ain't even no thing I
don't feel like less of a man because
everybody's in the same cities you end
up in L.A you end up in Atlanta
you know what I'm saying I want to have
those uh allies with people if I go to
Atlanta I need to be able to call
somebody in Atlanta that I [ __ ] with if
I'm straight not even got nothing to do
with no Street [ __ ] if I'm stranded I
need hey it's good to go to this
restaurant right here no it ain't you
know what I'm saying L.A St Louis New
Orleans whatever I'm at vice versa bro
you gotta build especially being an
artist it's like ain't no such thing as
being on your own I don't believe in
that bro I feel like we all stronger
together period so I don't believe in
that rap dishes
[ __ ] from my city right I definitely
ain't gonna rap beef with a [ __ ] from
another city what the [ __ ] I'm doing
that for the more gangster [ __ ] is to
get on the phone get on the phone get on
the phone that's the Real Gangsta [ __ ]
though all that internet the gangster
[ __ ] get on the phone talk to it what's
up what's going on bro what's the word
we good all right it's cool it's cool or
if it really is a difference let's link
up and solve it or if it's going
whatever it's gonna be keep it off the
internet let's do this amongst men so at
the end of the day our family safe uh
friends safe our name safe our brand our
career is safe we could continue getting
as much let's just talk about this [ __ ]
as men and that's what we missed right